Okay, also, was ich die Ansicht verteidigen möchte,
nenne ich die Autobahn, die ein wenig
zwischen den beiden Standardansichten liegt, jetzt die
Standardansichten, die Anachronismen, der
Animalismus, und die Idee ist, dass ich denke, dass
wir bei unseren beiden Häusern
eigentlich einen Mittelweg einschlagen sollten  Wir können
Adam Elizabeth nennen, die wir mögen, oder wir können es
psychologische Kontinuitäten nennen, wenn wir
möchten, was würden wir die Debatte denken
und etwas in der Mitte
anstreben  später in der Nähe eines
Organismus, der die
psychologische Kontinuität betrachtet, die auf einer
Art kausaler Verbundenheit unserer Verbindung basiert.
Vielleicht ist dies eine Art nicht verzweigte
Form. Dies sind alle Qualifikationen
und Ausarbeitungen, die Menschen
einbringen, die für die persönliche Identität notwendig und ausreichend sind
Die Beweise reichen nicht aus,
um die Bürger im Laufe der Zeit weiter zu kaufen
, und darüber reden wir. Es
gibt eine Identität. Ich rede
von mir, du redest von dir  u
was meint die person in dieser debatte
gut, die debatte dreht sich wirklich um mich und
deine liebe es geht um dich,
also wie die liebe sagt ich ist ein name für die selbstsucht
person was wir mit person meinen ist einfach das
was wir alle davon meinten  Als
du ich warst und das ist, was wir bekommen, okay,
das ist die nahe Hokkien-Ansicht. Animalismus.
Lassen Sie mich erklären, dass eine Erschöpfung
relevant ist. Ich denke, es ist sehr aufschlussreich, in
seiner Beseitigung zu unterscheiden, dass wir zwischen einer
Woche
anomaler These und einer starken
Tierart unterscheiden. Das Wochenende dieses Stücks ist
Dass wir Tiere sind, das ist die Aussage, dass wir Tiere sind,
die starke
animalische Zyste ist, dass wir Tiere sind,
und die zweite Würze
ist, dass Psychologie für die Art der Identität irrelevant ist,
dass die
Persistenzbedingungen der Art von Tieren, die wir sind,
so gerecht sind  zu Kondomen und dem starken
Animalismus, über den ich sprechen werde,
wenn ich sage, eine Plage in Ihren beiden Häusern,
die beiden Häuser sind Neonorganismen und
starker Animalismus, wie Sie sehen werden  Ich
glaube nicht, dass es dazwischen gibt, wenn Sie
Hybride sind, später wissen die Leute von den Kindern
oder aus der Literatur über die
psychologische Kontinuität. Gibt es
zwei Wege, die Sie gehen können, im Grunde können Sie
diesen Weg gehen, Schumacher, Ding, Schuhmacher, oder
Sie können die Mehrfachbelegung gehen
Denken Sie David Lewis. Ich denke, Sie haben die
gleiche Meinungsverschiedenheit im Fall von Behind
Review. Ich kenne die Nachrichten, okay, aber lassen Sie
mich jetzt erklären, warum
ich mehr
darüber gesagt
habe  kann es in Filmmutter finden Ich denke,
Sie können es auch in Lachs Lanford
in einer Zeitung finden, weil es aus gottlosen Gründen verzerrt ist
und ich denke, dass so
etwas in Segmenten funktioniert, aber ich
denke, sie unterscheiden nicht sorgfältig
zwischen diesen beiden Versionen und  Das liegt daran,
dass sie dazu neigen, entweder für irgendetwas zu argumentieren,
sie argumentieren für die beste Kandidatenversion.
Ich denke, die richtige Ansicht, wenn
Sie denken, dass diese
Ansicht die As-
Version sein muss, also werde ich das tun
Okay, jetzt habe ich die Option hinzugefügt. Ich denke,
Angriffe auf die Hybridansicht in 10 Tagen
waren sehr überzeugend Angriffssitz. Ich
denke, es gibt zwei Stellen, an denen er es angreift.
In der überarbeiteten Version seines Artikels war
ich liebe Funktionen  in der revidierten version
und auch in einem papiernamen vergesse ich in seiner
meinung die volumen, die ich auch meine, wo er
unterscheidet, wo er
ziemlich starke und schwache dinge produziert, und ich
denke, was er sagte, sehr, sehr einschränkend
, deshalb dachte ich, wir müssen  gehen
wir in die andere Richtung, wir werden
so gut hybride Dinge sein, warum diesen Mittelweg nehmen
, warum kann ich nicht mit dir
abhängen, du weißt, warum weiß sozusagen in beide
Richtungen schwingt,
gut ich denke, der Grund ist, dass wir
sehr stark sind  Intuition, die
anscheinend beide Positionen unterstützt, die wir haben
und von denen PLA-Erbauer sprechen, ist, wenn
Leute darüber sprechen, die Transplantationsintuition,
die offensichtlich das erste ist,
was die Neo-Begriffe zur
Unterstützung ihrer Position und auch anbieten
Leute, die erkannt haben, ist das
Restmenschenproblem, also haben
die Zugeteilten gesagt
, dass sie auf diese Art von Intuition hinweisen, aber dass
wir das Gesichtsproblem haben
Dass ich nie ein
ausreichend früher Fötus war, scheint auch
zu implizieren, dass ich nicht in einen
permanenten vegetativen Zustand eintreten kann, und
wir möchten wirklich all diese Dinge
sagen, die wir Ihnen sagen möchten. Gehen Sie mit
Ihrem Gehirn von Ihnen aus  Es gab viele
Funktionen und Sie könnten in einem
permanenten vegetativen Zustand enden. Ich
meine, ich meine, es geht nur um mich, deshalb denke ich
, wir könnten den Mittelweg gehen, wir
sollten versuchen, alle Intuitionen zu bewahren, die
wir können, also sagte ich, ich habe gewonnen  Ich
erzähle Ihnen nichts über Transplantationsintuition,
was natürlich das Argument
für die einzige Unterstützung ist. Entschuldigung,
was ich über die Transportintuition betonen möchte,
ist, dass sie
absolut nichts hat  mit Personen zu tun,
es ist keine Intuition über Personen. Ich
meine, es gibt einen Grund, warum Papier wie Sie es
gemacht hat, aber betont, dass Sie dies Ihrem Hund antun können
, und wir haben eine sehr starke
Intuition, dass Ihr Hund dahin geht, wo er
hingehört, oder sogar genauso stark geht
Da die Intuition, dass ich dorthin gehe, wo mein
Gehirn hingeht, unser Großhirn ist
, hat es nichts mit Menschen zu tun,
sondern mit Kreaturen mit einer
ausreichend interessanten und komplexen
Psychologie, die wir zwischen
Kreaturen derselben Psychologie unterscheiden, und
Schumaker sagt daher, er sagt nein, also
Hunde wie don
Das ist das Argument, warum wir
psychologische Kontinuität
als ausreichende Bedingung für die
Beharrlichkeit eines Jobs akzeptieren sollten. Tiere behandeln,
offensichtlich in vollkommen gutem Sinne, und
wir verlieren den gleichen Sinn wie Hunde, also
Schuhmacher, Leute, ich habe ein unhörbares
Ich  Ich denke nicht mehr nach, aber ich bin nicht
animalisch, sagt er, weil ich
das in der Sitzung nicht akzeptiere, okay, jetzt
gegen den Animalismus,
gegen den Ertrag  Aus
Sicht der psychologischen Kontinuität haben wir
die Merkmale von Problemen und das Problem
von Menschen
, die vergänglich sind, und das grundlegende Problem, das ich für Neo Lockean denke, ist
,
dass man nach jeder dieser Sichtweisen sagen muss, dass die
Person hineingekommen ist, wenn  Sie betrachten
die Person als eine individuelle Sache, deren
Persistenzbedingungen in
psychologischer Hinsicht gegeben sind, was eine Entscheidung
entfernt ist. Sie müssen sagen, die Person ist
später entstanden als das Tier,
und falls doch, kam die Person
heraus  vor dem Tier aufhören zu existieren, so dass
die Person eine Lebensgeschichte hat, die
mit einem Teil der
Lebensgeschichte des Tieres zusammenfällt. Personen sind kurzlebige
Wesen, deren Lebensgeschichte
typischerweise mit einem Teil der Lebensgeschichte eines Tieres zusammenfällt
Menschen, die einfach nicht in diese
unglücklichen späteren Stadien geraten und Science-
Fiction früh entlarven, können wir uns vorstellen, dass Sie
Menschen kennen, die entstehen, Sie
kennen Sumpfmenschen, die sich der Existenz verpflichten,
aber als Matte  Tatsächlich ist es eine
Implikation der psychologischen
Kontinuitätssicht, dass ich eine Art
kurzlebiges Wesen bin, und ich stimme
damit mit einem Wesen überein, das länger
lebt als ich,
ob Sie sagen, dass das langlebigere
Tier denkt, weil es was hat  Es dauert,
was passiert, dachte ich, oder ob Sie
mit Schuhmacher sagen, nein, es ist nicht
das Tier, mit dem die Person an
Größe denkt, und so unterscheidet das Tier,
mit dem die Person übereinstimmt, von dem
Tier, das die Person ist, also subtrahiert er
hier zwei Tiere  in verschiedenen Sinnen von
Tier ein Tier, das aus Idaho zu seinem Hund geschickt wurde,
weil die technischen biologischen Zellen,
die Sie sagen, für Erwachsene zu haben sind,
aber Sie müssen sich bei Personen verkürzen,
die mit länger lebenden Tieren zusammenfallen, okay,
und natürlich haben Sie auch das oh
Daher kann ich über das Album sprechen, um das
Problem der verbleibenden Person zu interviewen, das
ein einfacher Fall zu sein scheint, mit dem man
sich befassen muss, damit Ihr Großhirn
vor der Transplantation erhalten bleibt  In
einem Bad, das wirklich unterbewusst ist,
dort zu sein
, sieht aus wie das Schloss. Sie können sagen: Ja
, das bin ich.
Die Analytiker können nicht sagen, dass
ich es bin
Der neue Lockean scheint auf den ersten Blick
die einfache Antwort zu haben
, die ich habe,
nachdem ich gesprochen habe, und schreibe einfach ein bisschen nach
innen, tue die Dinge, die du so oder so sagen kannst
, damit es so aussieht, als würde nichts auf
beiden Seiten
alles gut tun, um alle Intuitionen zu schützen
und  und beide Wege gehen
gut, was ich argumentieren möchte, ist, wenn Sie es
eilig haben, können Sie diese Intuitionen akzeptieren,
weil Sie sagen können, welche Woche,
was nach Neo
Lockean für die persönliche Identität
ausreichend ist und was nach Ansicht des
Analytikers
ist  Ausreichend, wo diese Leute schief gehen,
ist es, was sie sagen, es ist notwendig,
und Sie brauchen nicht die psychologische
Kontinuitätsverblendung Larkin sagt, es ist nicht
notwendig, damit Sie im Permameter aufstehen können
manent vegetativen Zustand und Sie können
Sie sind wollen, Sie wollen und Sie brauchen nicht
die Begabung durch ihre biologische
rein biologische nicht psychologische
Kontinuität die typische und rekrutieren,
weil es ausreicht, die richtige Art von psychologischer Kontinuität zu haben, die
passenderweise als
nicht verzweigte Exzessruhe bezeichnet wird  Sie können
die ausreichenden Bedingungen akzeptieren, aber wir
fangen die notwendigen Bedingungen ein und
müssen daher das Beste aus beiden Welten bekommen. okay
okay
und das ist die Ansicht, die ich vertrete,
wie ich sagte, von den verschiedenen
Leuten, die ich in bestimmten Büchern
ausdrücklich erwähnt habe  In Kathleen denke ich, dass
es moderner ist, obwohl ich denke, dass Simon-
Sprachpapiere, die ich auf diese Weise nicht einmal kenne, sehr
gut
bin  Aber jetzt stellt sich die Frage, ob
Sie Hybriden sind, ob Sie daran interessiert sind, was Sie
darüber denken sollen, was Sie über KCC sagen sollen, um
ausreichende Bedingungen zu akzeptieren. Ihre
ausreichenden Bedingungen, die Sie sagen müssen
was soll man zu dem Fall sagen, dass man auf
der späteren Stufe eine Person hat,
die durch die psychologischen hinreichenden Bedingungen mit einer früheren Person verbunden ist,
und es gibt eine spätere Person, die auch
durch rein
biologische
hinreichende Bedingungen mit der einzigen Person verbunden ist  Wir sind sehr vertraut mit dieser Debatte,
wir sind sehr vertraut mit der Idee von
effizienten anderen Personen, wenn wir
über psychologische Kontinuität sprechen, nähern
Sie sich ihr, weil der Wind sehr
vertraut mit der Idee ist, dass
es zwei psychologische Kontinuitäten von einer
von dem geben könnte, was eine zu sein scheint  Ursprüngliche Person
und Leute, also wurde darüber debattiert
Leute Ansichten der Leute bekanntlich der beste
Kandidat Ansicht, dass Sie die Person sind,
die der beste Kandidat ist und auch von
Robin weiß, ich denke, der nächste
Fortsetzung und wenn Sie können
, habe ich viele raffinierte Versionen davon
Ich muss über dieses Ding stolpern und die
anderen, die alle gezögert haben, ist
die Position von David Lewis, was in einem solchen
Fall der Fall ist, in dem Sie zwei später haben
Menschen, die psychologisch mit
einer anderen Person verbunden sind,
es gab überhaupt keine einzige Person,
es gab die ganze Zeit zwei Menschen, die
hereinkamen, weil sie die gleichen Gedanken dachten,
und diese Ansicht wird von Lewis vertreten
, von Robinson, und auch von
mir  und ich weiß
nicht, sonst geht dieses Gerät mit
einer Meinungsverschiedenheit über ein berühmtes
Prinzip ein, das von Williams verteidigt, beleidigt und verteidigt
wird  Ich habe es verstanden, ich glaube,
er nennt es das eigene X&Y-Prinzip. Es
hat die Idee dieses Prinzips sehr
schwer zu formulieren gemacht, das ich
schrecklich gegeben habe, ist, dass die
Identität einer wetterbedingten Person mit einer Person
Teppichhand davon abhängen kann, was woanders vor sich geht
passiert mit anderen Leuten
sehr gute Leute das zu formulieren
weil man mit viel Identität auf Probleme
stößt Ich habe eine Formulierung versucht die
ich versuche in Bezug auf Ereignisse zu bevölkern
wenn zwei Ereignisse p sind  Künste der
Geschichte einer einzelnen Entität die Art, in welcher
Situation, dass in jeder zweiten Situation,
in der alle Ereignisse, die
in der Geschichte der Entität vorhanden sind, auch
vorhanden sind, dann sind diese beiden Ereignisse auch
ein Ereignis in der Geschichte einer einzelnen
Entität  Idee, diese Idee festzuhalten,
dass das, was anderswo
passiert, keinen Unterschied macht,
was Williams meiner Meinung nach in seiner
berühmten Anklage im Fall Robert J. Fox erneut
als Argument
gegen eine Art psychologische
Kontinuitätsansicht anführt, wie Paul sagte, wirklich
wollte  zu argumentieren, dass physische Körper tatsächlich
denken, dass er dem Anabolismus viel näher ist,
als die Leute vielleicht eingeladen werden, und ich
denke, in demselben Artikel hält er
uns im Grunde dafür, dass Fossum das
Konzept eines Tieres ignoriert
Was ich habe, hast du Animalismus ist mein neues
Okay, das ist also das Prinzip. Okay, ich
könnte ein paar mehr ins Detail gehen. Ich denke,
es gibt eine bessere Formulierung davon, denke ich
, die beste  Die Kombination des
Gedankens hinter diesem Prinzip ist
tatsächlich in der
von Robin Williams Robin Williams und er
ruft das Parkprinzip ein
, das besser als alles andere ist,
aber vielleicht in zu viele
technische Einzelheiten hineingezogen, und wir müssen rechtzeitig
für eine Diskussion in Ordnung sein  Die Grundidee,
die hinter der einzigen Antwort von
Whiteley liegt, warum wir diese Kluft
zwischen den Ansichten des besten Kandidaten und der Mehrfachbelegung haben,
auf die ich Sie
hinweisen möchte, auf die ich
denke, dass Sie die Geschichte kennen,
dass dies ein Schiff ist  Reparatur,
Austausch und Reparatur von Teilen der Vergangenheit,
die weggenommen und ersetzt werden, dieses grässliche
Zeug wieder weg, wie Florida
Kool-Aid sie zusammensetzt, macht ein neues
Schiff aus den ursprünglichen Planken, die
schmutzigen nebeneinander oder zwei Schiffe,
die das ursprüngliche Schiff sind  Wenn Sie jetzt an
diese komplexe Situation in der Mitte denken,
wo dies die beiden Schiffe sind,
könnten Sie nur an Reparatur
und Austausch von Teilen denken  Sie ersetzten
einfach weggeworfene Nudeln, warum kann man darüber
nachdenken, einfach Demontage und
Wiederaufbau zu platzieren, ob Pflanzen nicht
ersetzt werden, und wir können nicht glauben, dass Sie in der
ersten Situation,
in einer Kampfsituation, eine
ausreichende Bedingung für das
Bestehen eines Schiffes haben  In der ersten Situation sind die
effizientesten Bedingungen für die Beharrlichkeit dessen,
was Sie gesagt haben, die zweite
Situation besteht, wenn Sie zwei
ausreichende Bedingungen erfüllt haben, nämlich in
diesem Jahr, und Sie könnten sagen, dass
Sie sagen könnten, dass Sie der beste
Kandidat sind und  Die meisten von uns würden sagen, dass
das Reparaturschiff der beste Kandidat in
dieser Gleichung ist, der andere ist ein
Kandidat der besten Fakultät, bis Sie
die beste Tageszeit wählen, um das andere zu zählen,
was Sie sagen können, wenn Sie das
Publikum mögen  Weiß Prinzip kann man das nicht
sagen, weil man sagen muss, dass die
Geschichte, die durch die Linie dargestellt wird,
die Ryland-Kreuzung
in beiden Situationen darstellt, und was
22 w passiert  hier das Dock, wo die Linien sind
andere die unterbrochenen Linien sind es woanders
ist irrelevant,
also wenn Sie für so etwas wie die nächste
weiße Zaunwand gehen, würden wir sagen, gut, damit
Sie nicht bezahlen müssen und es sogar
auf beide ernsthafte Konten übertragen, weil  Ich
wusste, okay, okay, also bekommst du diese Debatte, nein,
okay, also haben wir zwei Versionen von
- ich denke, ich denke, wo wir die Willensbildung gehandhabt haben,
ist eine Art beste Kandidatenversion,
und er verwendet eine gartenbauliche
Analogie, um zu erklären, was vor sich geht,
sagt er  Wenn Sie eine Transplantation durchführen
, sollten wir dies mit dem Pflanzen von Baumwolle vergleichen,
aber was passiert, wenn ein
Großhirn transplantiert wird, ist
das Großhirn nicht mit dem
Schneiden des restlichen Körpers zu
vergleichen, sondern mit dem
Schneiden des Großhirns ist die dominante
Pflanze und so weiter  Das Großhirn, das die Pflanze
aufnehmen kann, enthält die drei Überreste,
die dominante
Pflanze  Wenn wir von einem größeren Körper und dem
ganzen Körper mit leeren Händen zurückgelassen wurden,
ist das wie das Coaching
und was du tust, ist ein neues
Nickerchen, das ist eine neue Existenz, also nimmst du eine
beste Kandidatenansicht, sagst du in diesem
Fall  Eine Person geht mit der Psychologie mit
dem Großhirn und eine neue Person
entsteht mit dem Audio ohne
Hellseher ohne Psychologie und er
sagt auch, wenn Sie darüber nachdenken, wenn Sie
an die letzte Phase der gesamten Transplantation denken,
so nehmen Sie  Jeder
kennt die Bodenrouten und
Brownies. Das Radio. Robinson ist der Körper.
Nehmen Sie nicht die letzte Phase, in der
das Gehirn oder das
Großhirn in die Körper des Boxens transplantiert wird.
Robinson-Schule. In dieser Situation
wollen wir sagen, dass dies der Fall ist  wie
Pflanzentransplantation und der Bodybuilder ist
es der Boden und er hat Angst, dass es eine
minderwertige Pflanze ist und deshalb hört es auf
zu existieren, also wenn Sie, wenn Sie
so Robeson gehen, diese Person nicht
überlebt, überlebt er  Bis das Gehirn in
das Großhirn gesteckt wird,
hört er auf zu existieren, weil es einen
dominanten Willenssub-befreiten Gutachter gibt, und so
hört die Person auf zu existieren, also ist das
Entscheidende, dass seine Größe
das Wichtigste dabei sein wird  Konto
Okay, das ist die Ansicht, die Sie einnehmen,
wenn Sie es tun, also tun Sie es
Sie können den Block weiter nehmen und
wie vorhersehbar sein, wenn Sie das tun, haben
Sie ein großes Vertrauen, nicht nur einen
Spezialfall von Fisher. Sie behandeln die Spaltung als
die.
Ich habe das Motiv. Belegung Thesen drei sind
ausreichend. Sie haben zwei und dann sagen Sie
vor der Spaltung stellt sich heraus, und
das Fehlende hier ist ein großes Transplantat,
das den leeren Körper
zurücklässt  Es ist nicht so,
dass es zwei Arten von Tieren sind, weil
ein einzelnes Tier durch
psychologische Kontinuität und dann durch
biologische Kontinuität oder umgekehrt bestehen kann,
und ich meine, Sie können Sie
hacken und verändern, also gibt es eine einzige
Tierart, aber das ist es  Der Kontrast, den
Sie machen, ist, bestehen Sie auf ein
zahnempfindliches Tier, okay, und Sie können darüber nachdenken,
wie ich sagte, Sie sollten darüber nachdenken, wenn
Sie an
Gehirntransplantationen denken. Ich denke, es ist hilfreich, zuerst an
sie im Fall von Hunden zu denken  Weil
Sie nur Ablenkungen bekommen, wenn
Sie an Personen denken, und die
Intuition ist wie folgt, also
sagen Sie, nun, es gab immer zwei
Tiere, die ich beseitigen musste, und eines
davon unterstützt die Fakultät, was
beharrlich ist  von einer davon wird beharrlich
von das ist, wo du sagen musst, wenn du
nach vorne gehst, siehst du vielleicht Bob, aber
das ist es, was du sagen willst, was auch immer du sagst,
sag nichts, okay, wenn du jetzt
an Leute denkst, bringst du
etwas mit  g extra etwas mehr etwas
ist nicht das im Doc-Fall, nämlich
das Selbstbewusstsein der Leute, also
benutzen die Leute das Wort ich, also wenn es
hier zwei Tiere gibt und sie beide
denken, ist die Frage, wer ich bin
Das ist die Frage, wenn nicht vielleicht, aber ich
kann sie stellen, damit Sie sich jetzt Sorgen
darüber machen, wie die Verwendung von I, wie die Referenz
RI bestimmt wird und was
dazu zu sagen ist,
und das wird dem Gelehrten gesagt, was
los ist  zwischen mir und Alec, wenn niemand
sonst. Ich möchte nur kurz zwei
Dinge dazu sagen, weil ich
zuerst von den anderen Dingen loskommen muss. Ich
möchte sagen, ich will nicht
Das Pronomen der ersten Person bezieht sich garantiert
auf den Denker, und hier gebe ich
Pop Snowden Anerkennung, aber ich
weiß nicht, also denke ich darüber nach, wie Sie
diese Komplikation umgehen können, aber ich
möchte mit den letzten Dingen fortfahren  in der
zeit, die ich so habe, habe ich über
die endphase der transp gesprochen  Lant in the in
the toilet case if you're high
have a view und was Louie Button sagt
ist in diesem Fall hat das Pony nicht
aufgehört zu existieren die zweiten Gedanken
über nur Probleme gut die Abstimmung wird
Belegungstheorien whoo wie man
erwarten kann  Wir betrachten dies als
Fusion. Wir wissen, dass wir wissen, wie ich
über Fischen spreche. Wir sollten
genauso über Fusion sprechen
Das
ist die Geschichte, die ich kenne, tun es Nachrichten Natürlich
ist für Dimensionalisiert
jetzt der Punkt ist, dass das Argument,
das Sie dazu bringt, was das Fahren über
diese Position herleitet, und das
Prinzip unter Williams ist,
vielleicht wäre es für mich, aber er scheint, dass
es eine große Sache gibt
Macht langsam und es ist überhaupt nicht
offensichtlich, dass du ein Vierdimensionaler sein musst, um
mit Williams in diesem
Prinzip mitzuhalten, also sehe ich nicht, dass dies
notwendig ist. Natürlich kannst du sagen, oh,
Mutter  Vierdimensional, vergessen wir das,
das kann zusammen mit Paul Diamond verworfen werden, müssen
Sie nicht
etwas über die Umgebung des Publikums sagen,
ok, ok, wir haben also eine
Menge Dokumente, wenn Sie die
Belegungsansicht von Sacramento hätten, was ist  Art
von dem, was Sie erwarten würden, denn kommen Sie zur Ansicht von
Option C, aber es gibt eine Art
von mehreren Insassen, die Sie nicht
haben, die Sie auf dem psychologischen Neo-Lock
und der psychologischen Ansicht haben, die Sie haben. Ich stimme
NICHT mit einem bestimmten Tier überein.
Ich '  Ich bin ein denkendes Ding. Ich bin ein Tier. Ich bin
offensichtlich
solche Dinge passieren, also sind diese
Dinge nicht, dass ich mir passiert bin und
sie sind mir in der Vergangenheit nicht
passiert, sie sind vielen Menschen von
Generation zu Generation passiert, sie müssen irgendetwas
für die letzten Generationen tun,
also bist du eine Art  des Gebäudes, das ich gemacht habe
Das heißt, ich wurde offensichtlich gezeugt, nicht wahr
, das bedeutet nicht, dass ich nicht das Tier bin,
das sich in einem fötalen Zustand befand, der vielleicht
weiß, dass ich hoffe, dass ich in einem permanenten vegetativen
Zustand
bin, dass ich definitiv ein denkendes Ding bin, dass
sie nur Dinge hier wollen  Nun, was ist
hier der Unterschied zwischen der
anstößigen
Art der Besetzung, zu der sich Neo
Lockean verpflichtet hat, und dieser
Art der Besetzung, die das
hybride Dienstleistungskomitee
aufgrund des neuen Dokuments begrüßen soll? Hier gibt es zwei
Dinge  Da ist die Person
, die das fötale Stadium nicht ausreichend früh
im Nokia hatte, was mit einem
Tier zusammenfällt, das andere Menschen inszenieren, und
wenn wir diese Konstitution verwenden, können Sie
sagen, dass Noonan ein Tier ist, das ein
frühes Stadium hatte, aber Sie können nicht sagen, dass Noonan es ist
ganz vorsichtig okay
und mit der bühne so der unterschied
ob du jetzt sagst das das tier mit
dem das mit dem ich bin zufällig
laut dem neonazi auf dich ein
denker ist ich meine es scheint das
ich es bin  Denken Sie, weil es hat, was er
schmeckt, es hat die Erhöhung, was ich
dachte, und es ist so etwas wie das, was ich für
eine lange Zeit bekommen habe, eine Frau, die für eine lange Zeit bereit ist,
also ob ich in einem
vegetativen Zustand gelandet bin, aber es scheint
eine Klasse gegangen zu sein  dass alles notwendig ist
, warum ist es nicht, denke ich, der Mensch hat gesagt, dass es
kein Denker ist, weil Denken eine
dicke Party ist und wir gerne zwischen
dicken und dünnen Partys sehen, und so, obwohl
er akzeptiert, dass es hier zwei zusammenfallende
Entitäten gibt, und er akzeptiert das jede
von ihnen ist ein tierischer
Sinn, weil ich ein Tier in dem Sinne bin,
in dem ein Hund ein Tier ist, und in diesem
Sinne kann ein Tier das
Willensmädchen mit diesem Raum überleben,
der mit mir zusammenfällt, der
vor mir entstand und  das ist
es, dass ich kein Denker in dem Sinne
bin, wie ich es bin, weil ich die dicke
Eigenschaft habe zu denken, ob Sie sagen,
dass ich sagen werde, dass es zwei
Zufallsdinge gibt und dass es bedeutet, dass Sie
immer noch zwei Denker haben
in diesem c  Als eine kurzlebigere Person und
ein längerlebigeres Tier, und sie
sind Vorfällen ausgesetzt, und ich meine, das
scheint mir das zu sein, was mir Objekte zu sein scheinen,
denn das ist passiert,
dass das Tier bestimmte Eigenschaften erworben hat,
seit es bestimmte Eigenschaften erworben hat
Zu dem neuen Dokument, das
Sie sagen möchten, ist eine Person
entstanden, etwas Neues, eine Person
ist entstanden, aber
was richtig zu sagen scheint, ist, dass das
Unterwasser durch bestimmte Eigenschaften und
ähnlich später, wenn ich in einen
früheren Zustand verfalle  Aus der neuen
psychologischen Sichtweise von Locke muss man sagen,
dass eine Person, eine individuelle
Sache aufgehört hat zu existieren, also ein Tier
weiter existiert, das ist genau das
, was passiert ist, eine Person, die
verloren gegangen ist, ein Tier, es sind keine bestimmten
Eigenschaften,
also denke ich, dass es so ist  Ein großes Ich meine, was an
der psychologischen Seite von Lockean falsch
ist, um es loszulassen, es heißt,
es ist das, was über Personen gesagt wird,
was teilweise Beobachter ist  Wenn Sie an
Teenager denken, nehmen Sie an, ab einem bestimmten
Stadium wird der Himmel zu einem
Teenager  Neu ist am
dreizehnten Geburtstag von Cabbage
entstanden und Gott und geht an
Kevins 20. Geburtstag ins Leben. Wollen Sie
wirklich sagen, dass Kevin eine Person ist, mit
der Sie sich auskennen? Nein, und ich denke, das ist
die Art von Bild, die wir haben
zwischen mir das tier hier eine
befestigung hier wenn du bist wenn du
wärst wenn du ein vierdimensionaler
bist hast du daran gedacht vertagt du wirst in der tat
sagen weil etwas entsteht
wenn kami ein
teenager wird und untergeht wenn
kevin ist  Zwanzig werden
im Laufe der Zeit
zu Zwanzig. Dinge entstehen und vergehen die
ganze Zeit,
aber die Vorstellung, dass sich die Art von Änderungen so ändert,
aber ich  Wenn du das nicht nimmst, wirst du sie nicht
nehmen wollen,
aber der Neo-
Lockean muss sagen, dass Schuhmacher sowieso sagen müssen,
dass Schuhmacher nicht an der Reihe sind,
also ist es hier keine 4-dimensionale Liste
Langweilig, ich sagte, er liebt Schadenersatz,
aber er muss drin bleiben, es gab zwei
zufällige Dinge, eines davon Schoko-
Vanille, und das entstand,
weil die Person, die länger lebt,
bestimmte psychische Veränderungen durchmachte,
und das scheint mir
ausgesprochen verwerflich zu sein
der Neo Lockean Sie so zwei Süchtige
fragen, wie viele wie viele denkende
Dinge es gibt, wo Sie stehen
20 mir ist das gerade passiert
- vorausgesetzt, ich denke, die Angewohnheit ist gering, ich
kann bisher sehen, dass es vielleicht das Beste ist, Baby zu
nehmen  Kandidatenansicht, die
beleidigend ist. Sie können die
Intuition beider Seiten einfangen, welchen Weg Sie einschlagen sollten. Ich
weiß nicht, wie Sie beide Seiten präsentieren sollen,
aber ich denke, es wird
auf diese Weise in die Debatte eingebettet, es ist ein Weg, es ist das
Wa  y weiterleiten okay vielen Dank